today on the matt well show the latest
groomer innovation is sexually
suggestive drag shows at high schools
there is more than one example of this
kind of thing from just this month we'll
talk about it today also more questions
about the law enforcement response to
the shooting in texas police officials
have made some very damning statements
in an effort to vindicate themselves
we'll go through those also today and
the secretary of education endorses
gender transitioning children in school
without parental consent endorses it in
a roundabout way but still endorses it
in our daily cancellation a school
district bans the word chief because it
appropriates from native americans
there's just one problem there actually
several we'll talk about that today and
much more on the matt walsh show
[Music]
well it's finally happened the fed is
realizing the dire straits our economy
is in thanks to our loose monetary
policy apparently you can't just spend
trillions every year with no
repercussions who would have thought now
to play catch-up the fed has been
raising rates and plans to seven uh
plans to do that seven times this year
you're already starting to see those
ripple effects in the housing market as
people's buying power diminishes you
consider what could happen in the stock
market if our economy really stalls out
don't wait till it happens take some of
your profits from the stock market now
and solidify them with gold from birch
gold throughout history gold has
maintained value better than any other
investment in the entire world so all
you gotta do is text walsh to 98 98 98
for a free zero obligation info kit on
holding gold in a tax sheltered
retirement account join the thousands of
happy birch gold customers with
countless five-star reviews and an
a-plus rating with the better business
bureau i trust the professionals at
birch gold and so should you text walsh
to 98 98 98 and secure the gains you've
made while you can again
for the last time text walsh to 98 98 98
right now
well it happened again this week a drag
show at a high school hosted by that
school's so-called gay straight alliance
this time it was ann kenny high school
in iowa cross-dressing males were
brought up on stage in the school's
auditorium to gyrate around on stage in
their woman face makeup and absurd
outfits according to the daily wire
report one of the performers also
delivered a speech about his gender
transition he told the kids in
attendance quote when i felt like i
couldn't express myself in school or i
felt like i had to look like this at
school
i could be whoever i wanted to be and i
started to think what is gender and i
realized that no matter what pronouns
you use you are who you are i know on
the inside that i am who i am
now it doesn't mean anything of course
but it's not supposed to mean anything
there is a message here but it's not one
that is communicated through
intelligible coherent sentences most of
the time
libs of tick tock which first published
the videos of this event
says that students
the the minors at the school were also
brought up on stage to dance
so for the school's part they say that
this was not an official school event
and that it was not conducted in
accordance with their policies
it is under investigation they say they
want to make sure that the drag show was
in accordance with their policies uh
looks like it might not have been
but it's of course impossible to believe
that the auditorium was used for a drag
show and the administrators didn't know
about it or that they did know about it
but they didn't know what a drag show
entails
that's that seems to be kind of what
they're claiming that uh that they saw
the videos and they're like oh that's a
drag show well that's clearly we don't
want that
but they're feigning ignorance of course
which is the same thing that happened a
week or two earlier when a different
high school this one in pennsylvania
notice the states involved here iowa
pennsylvania okay not not uh
washington vermont california although
these things are certainly happening in
those states as well
but uh they held their own gsa sponsored
drag show grown men in makeup wigs
thongs performed a burlesque routine for
children at hempfield high school
this is certainly not something that
any mentally stable person wants to see
particularly right around lunchtime but
i'm going to play some of the footage
for you anyway because you need to
understand just how over the top
creepily sexual this was uh
here it is
[Music]
okay surprise enough of that
so you get the you get the gist
uh nothing to see there just a grown man
and a thong on all fours shaking his ass
for a group of school children
the administrators in this case say that
they were appalled by what took place
but coincidentally they were only
appalled when parents found out about it
and complained
a teacher named kelly tyson who's an
advisor for the gsa club
expressed her delight and joy in
watching this pedophilic display but she
also confessed to something else
inadvertently which is quite damning for
the school administration she wrote in a
social media post quote i don't know how
to explain the sheer joy i feel in my
bones when these queens come take time
out of their busy schedules to perform
for us year three
and to be with my students as gsa
co-advisor and a queer teacher it makes
me emotional to think of this space
we've created i would have loved nothing
more than have a space like they have an
opportunity to attend their own drag
show
year three she says
so they've been doing this for uh three
years and the administration just
noticed how appalling it is
that's what we're supposed to believe
and it's obviously total nonsense so
what is actually going on here and
what's with the leftist obsession with
drag in particular
they've got drag queens story hour drag
shows at high schools drag shows at all
their gay pride events drag shows on tv
drag reality shows
why
along with all the other problems with
this stuff i mean the many many problems
especially when kids are involved
it's not even like these dudes are
talented dancers or performers they're
just weird-looking guys and ugly outfits
dancing badly on stage what's the point
i mean even if it was only adults in the
audience
why would anyone want to see that
why has drag in particular become such a
central component of the left's culture
war strategy i think there are a few
reasons for that
it's worth thinking about one
drag contributes to the sort of
costumification
if i can coin my own word of womanhood
the drag performer makes womanhood into
this
cartoonish gaudy ridiculous thing he
turns it into a stage performance a
costume it's no surprise that the drag
queen uh at the one school event gave a
speech about gender identity and talked
about how drag helped him get in touch
with his inner female identity because
this is how the left sees womanhood they
see it as a cheap degraded
hypersexualized thing which is
interchangeable and superficial and can
be taken off just as easily as it's put
on
that's one reason why they love drag
because of of what it does to womanhood
how it portrays womanhood how it
cheapens it that's what they like about
it
uh also
drag is an assault not only on
femininity but also on beauty and
anything that assaults femininity also
assaults beauty
it is a protest against traditional
notions of beauty womanhood and so on
everything the left does is targeted to
tear down whatever they think is
traditional as traditional to them is
synonymous with archaic or oppressive
and when these drag performances are
staged for children
it's also meant to tear down and sever
the parent-child relationship the author
carl truman who appears by the way in my
film what is a woman premiering june 1st
uh which is next wednesday make sure
you're there get your membership um he
made this point an interview with the
daily wire published today which is very
interesting and worth going to read the
whole thing
but he says quoting from he says
children are the perfect targets for
groups whose purpose is the subversion
of subversion of the parent-child bond
and the consequent strengthening of the
power of a progressive establishment
destroy the bond between parents and
children and you have destroyed the most
powerful and influential pre-political
bond of influence and loyalty that
stands in the way of various lobby
groups trying to drive the direction of
our culture
i couldn't have said it better myself
but there's one other factor to consider
here and that is
cowardice
okay there's a there's a whole lot of
cowardice that leads to things like this
happening in our schools
the administrators
are of course lying when they claim
ignorance they know that this sort of
thing is going on
every time a teacher is
exposed for grooming indoctrinating
children the administrators know about
it they knew about it before that it's
never subtle
i mean you see all these tick tock
videos that they're posting first of all
they're posting tick tock videos they're
not hiding it
and then you see they've got all the
excuses they always have rainbow flags
draped all over their classrooms
you know and they've got the purple hair
and rainbow earrings it's like they've a
walking advertisement saying this is the
only thing i care about this is all i
talk to my kids about
not hiding their intentions
so do the people in charge go along with
this
because they are themselves lgbt
radicals intent on grooming children in
some cases yes certainly
but especially if we're talking about a
situation in california or vermont or uh
washington state or something like that
then then it's it's very likely that
everybody involved if we're talking
about a school isn't is an lgbt radical
but at a school in iowa
are the administrators a bunch of lgbt
extremists
maybe but probably not
they simply lack the courage to tell the
lgbt extremists to cool it knock it off
keep the crap out of the classroom
they know better some of them
they don't have the backbone to stand up
to the lgbt bullies so they let them do
whatever they want and i do mean
whatever they want
until the backlash from outside
forces their hand
so this is the the formula
lgbt extremism
and the cowardice that enables it
you add that together and you get
cross-dressing adult men twerking on
stage for children
and you get a whole lot more besides
that
and none of it of course is good
we'll get now to our five headlines
[Music]
well here's a fact you might not know
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you are helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-abortion causes and candidates
common question i get from my listeners
all the time is what can i do to help
turn the tides in the culture war well
here's a great first step defund the
abortionist don't let them uh take your
money and use it to further policies you
don't believe in switch to charity level
today and they will spend five percent
of your monthly plan price to uh on on
any pro-life charity of your choice
charity mobile offers as well the latest
5g phones with no device or service
contracts plus they got great nationwide
coverage if this sounds like a hassle to
make the switch i assure you it is not
charity mobile makes switching from your
current carrier painless their live
customer service is exceptional and
they're going to be ready to guide you
through the process very easily you can
keep your number and in most cases you
can keep your phone but if you want a
new phone you could take advantage of my
special offer and get a free cell phone
with free activation all you have to do
is call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walls to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh and join the fight for
life with charity mobile today
so we're going to stay on this theme of
cowardice as we go down to texas um
where more details are emerging about
the circumstances around the shooting at
rob elementary school
and i say details are emerging but this
is uh that makes it sound almost like a
passive natural process of things sort
of bubbling to the surface oh look
there's another detail that's not what's
happening here it's becoming more and
more apparent that what we were told in
the first 24 hours was wrong and not
mistakenly wrong but a lie lies many
lies
we were told we were lied to
i mean remember we were told early on
not just like rumors on social media but
we were told from
uh press conferences from politicians
and and officials that
you know the shooter was engaged
as soon as he arrived at the school
people police were on hand right away
engaging the shooter
you know uh saving lives that's what
governor abbott said that it's like they
were they were there they saved lives
this is what we were told right
um doesn't appear to be the case
and
even now they're being very selective in
what they tell us
but what they have admitted so far or
really just yesterday is
damning for the police
now you start with all of the qualifiers
and disclaimers that we still there's
still a lot we don't know
but the reason we don't know a lot of
these things because we're not being
told them
right
and there are there are details
that they're being at least vague about
that
many of which like they must know i know
there are certain things that it takes
time to figure out
but then there are other details that of
course you're going to know this
wouldn't take long to figure that out
but they're being vague a lot of those
about about a lot of those things too
so that puts us in the position of
there's still a lot we don't know
so you have those disclaimers
um but even so
based on what we've been told
video that has now come out
and everything added together um it
seems like it's a very damning situation
for the police who responded there was a
press conference with the texas police
official yesterday which gave us the
most complete picture so far
and so here's what we learned and um and
this is what the police official told us
he told us that the shooter
crashed his car
near the school
got out with his rifle in hand
and started firing at random people and
buildings and he didn't he didn't hit
anybody but he was just like walking
around firing his his rifle
he started walking towards the school
okay
12 minutes later
after walking around casually shooting
right
he he goes into the school
12 minutes later
so the clock's already ticking we got 12
minutes by the time he gets to the
school
and then this listen
he walked in uninstructed initially so
from
the grandmother's house to the garbage
to the school
into the school
he was not confronted by anybody
to clear the record on that
four minutes later
law enforcement are coming in
to solve this problem
he walks in and it appears that the door
is just unlocked
um there's no unobstructed
now there were there were
we were told again early on the the
claim was or the the
the version of events we were getting in
the first few hours was that there was a
uh there was a school resource officer
there and that he was engaged somehow
with the resource officer and then got
patent it was always unclear like how
did that happen how did he get back but
that's that's not the case you just walk
right into the school
and this is even though there was an
active shooter
in
the area
okay and four minutes later the cops
come in
that by the way is 14 minutes after the
first 9-1-1 call was made because the
first diamond one call was made um two
minutes after the guy got out of his car
he got out of his car i believe at 11 28
a.m 11 30 a.m
somebody makes a 911 call and says
there's a guy walking around with a
rifle shooting
so the school should have been on
lockdown there's an active shooter
nearby
lock all the doors lock down situation
but it seems like that they didn't even
lock the front door of the school or
whatever door this guy walked into
for so it's actually 14 minutes after
the first 9-1 call that the cops finally
show up
but the shooter is not killed for
another hour
he was in that classroom executing
little kids for an hour
while the cops were outside
an hour
they said that he was barricaded in the
classroom we were told by this police
official he's barricaded the classroom
they said that they they you know he
they went in
four minutes later and then they
received fire
and they retreated and he didn't use the
word retreat but that's what they did
they didn't go in the room because they
were getting shot at
uh and he was barricaded in the
classroom now
why didn't the cops go in
and i think we i think we all kind of
know it's because they were afraid
but why what what are you what's what's
their version of events here why didn't
they go in why did why didn't they reach
the door uh the official in the press
conference was asked this question
here's his answer rather his non-answer
listen
you guys have said that he was
barricaded
can you explain to us how he was
barricaded and why you guys cannot
breach that door so i am taking all your
questions and consideration we will be
doing updates we will be doing that
answer those questions we answered that
question now sir what did you do
because we've been given a lot of bad
information so why don't you clear all
of this up now and explain to us how it
is that your officers were in there for
an hour yes rescuing people but yet no
one was able to get inside that room
we will we will circle back with you we
want to answer all your questions we
want to give you the why that's that's
our job so give us time i'm taking all
your questions i'm taking them back to
talk to the team
and uh
we'll talk soon
um so he's not gonna answer that
question of why they didn't why didn't
breach the door i mean what how how
could this guy have barricaded the door
in a way where they couldn't have easily
gotten in
so it's just i don't buy
any excuse that they couldn't get in the
door
okay did he i mean did the shooter did
he walk in did he have like planks of
wood and a hammer and nails and he
nailed it no like he might have locked
the door if the door even had a lock on
it
that's about it pretty sure cops know
how to get in and get through locked
doors wouldn't be able to do their job
if they didn't
okay if this was a drug bust
and they thought there was a fifty
thousand dollars in drug money in in in
that room they'd find a way to get in
wouldn't they
so why didn't they get in
he's in there
with young children
shooting
now we're also told i watched the entire
press conference and uh
he says that
that they that they uh they you know
they they were treated again he does he
doesn't use the word retreat whatever
word he uses but that's what they did
they were treated and uh then they start
calling backup he says they're trying to
get back up in there and they also are
getting negotiators
and they they're to talk to the guy but
then he also says that as far as he
knows they never actually made contact
because this was not a hostage situation
he was killing the kids
and it's also not true and this is this
is one excuse i've seen on social media
quite a horrific morbid excuse but well
uh the most of the shooting happened in
the first four minutes by the time they
got there right this is the excuse that
i've heard from some people by the time
the cops got there um the kids he'd
already killed everybody in the room
but first of all there's no way the cops
would know that like all they would know
by the time they get there is that he's
in that room and he's been shooting
people and that's all they should need
to know
you go in i don't care if it's just you
alone you go in
but also it's it's not there were
survivors
from that room
there were also children
who
were taken out of the room alive and
then died in a hospital
what if they had been rescued an hour
earlier may they have survived
well we'll never know will
we those cops stood around for an hour
while that man was
executing children
now a different texas police official
appeared on cnn last night and gave
something of an answer as to why they
didn't go in uh the clip is i think this
clip's two minutes long but it's it's i
think you need to hear the whole thing
so let's play it
so what we do know uh wolf is that there
was multiple officers that arrived on
scene there was three officers that
arrived that made entry
at one of the entrances where the gunman
actually made entrance to we had other
another four officers that made uh entry
at the other entrance of the school so
there was officers inside that school as
they were taking gunfire they were also
calling in for reinforcement uh backup
tactical teams uh snipers
any additional personnel that could
arrive to assist to not only with to
with the situation but also to assist in
evacuating uh students and teachers at
that time that's when a u.s border
patrol tactical officer arrived also
with a zavala county sheriff's deputy as
well as two additional
uvalde police department officers were
able to go into that classroom
with a ballistic shield as cover and of
course we know that one of those
officers an agent actually was uh was
shot uh was grazed on the top of the
head but they were able to
shoot and kill the suspect and preserve
any other life we know that there was
other injured children inside that
costume that they were able to save as
well and get them to and get them to
cover and at that point it became a
recovery process a rescue operation
trying to rescue the injured and also
any other potential children or teachers
that were inside those classrooms
but dumb current best practices
lieutenant call for officers to disable
a shooter as quickly as possible
regardless of how many officers are
actually on site
correct the active shooter situation you
want to stop the killing you want to
preserve life but also
one thing that
of course the american people need to
understand is that officers are making
entry into this building
they do not know where the gunman is
they are hearing gunshots they are they
are receiving gunshots at that point if
they if they proceeded any further not
knowing where this suspect was at they
could have been shot they could have
been killed and at that point that
gunman would have the opportunity to
kill other people inside that school
oh well there it is there
at the end right uh well if they had
gone in then they could have been shot
and killed
right
yeah they could have been
but that's your job
your police officer and those are little
children inside that building
so your job is actually to put yourself
in between that bad guy and the child
even if it means you get shot and killed
in the process
that's your job
don't want to do that job
get a different job
go work at walmart
i hear they're hiring
if that's not a job you're prepared to
do i mean they're waiting around that's
why i wanted to hear the clip cause he
says they're waiting for the ballistic
shield so they can go in
you're waiting for a ballistic shield
while kids are being executed
where is your honor as a man
how can you even live with yourself
that's why i say look no one can know
how they would react in a situation like
this until you're in the situation but i
just
it
how would you not just
have
this compulsion i mean
every fiber of your being
i would think
would be driving you into that room
because i you how could you live with
yourself afterwards yeah if you don't go
in
like if you go in you might be shot and
killed
but if you don't go in and you sit
outside while kids are dying you're
gonna wish that you had been killed
i would rather be dead than live with
that for the rest of my life i couldn't
live with it
so it's honor and courage which brings
you in the door but also in a in a in a
sort of strange way it's all it is also
its own form of kind of
self-preservation as well on top of
everything else because
who wants to live a life like that for
the rest of knowing
that you could have done something while
these kids are being slaughtered but you
were standing outside waiting for a
shield so you could go in
oh but they weren't doing nothing uh
they were as video has has come out and
shown they were handcuffing parents and
reportedly tasing at least one of them
to stop the parents from going in to
rescue their children
there's video very heart-wrenching video
of the pair groups of parents outside
screaming at the cops going and save my
children and they weren't doing it the
parents tried to go in themselves and
they would stop the parents
now listen
if they were already in the process
of being if they were in a gunfight with
this uh with this guy
and they were in the and they were
already there trying to rescue the kids
then i understand keeping the parents
out because then you're just going to
add to the body count you're not going
to let parents go run into the middle of
that but if you're not doing anything
and you're if you're just waiting for an
hour for more people to show up
then uh
then yes i think you'll at least let the
if you're not willing to do it and there
are children who are being killed then
if someone else is willing to do it you
let them do it
this is uh it's
just totally unconscionable and
going back to the disclaimer there's
still more details we don't know but i
just don't know
given what they're telling us now i i
don't know what additional detail could
come out
that would vindicate the officers on the
scene in this case i just don't know
what we could find out that would change
i just i can't imagine what it could
possibly be
they're telling us themselves they were
there for an hour before they went in as
far as i'm concerned that's like all we
need to know
there's no excuse for that
the only excuse conceivable
would be if they showed up there
and he was locked in that room with
those kids and he hadn't killed any and
he hadn't started shooting yet
now you're hesitant to charge in there
because it is a hostage situation and
you don't want to do anything that
provokes them to start killing hostages
so that i understand okay in a situation
like that yes you stand and you wait for
negotiators and all that you come up
with strategy
but uh he had already started shooting
he was shooting before he walked in the
damn door
we got a real crisis of cowardice in
this culture and all of our institutions
are infested with it
um all of them especially government
institutions
doesn't mean everybody in these
institutions are cowards that's
certainly not the case
there are plenty of
heroic police officers no doubt about it
but i can't tell you how depressing it
is
of course and devastating this has this
happened at all but especially i mean in
in in texas of all places
then you have cops in texas like you
would like to think that in texas of all
places they would they would just be
they would rush in there
but it's a real it's the rot of
cowardice across our institutions
think about the teachers at co around
covet again not every teacher
but there were enough of them too many
of them the teachers in in
during during covet who'd rather shut
the schools down for a year
kids be damned doesn't matter what it
does to the kids shut the schools down
because i don't want to get sick i don't
want to risk myself for the sake of
these kids
no courage no honor
but here's here's the the real point
about all this
well this is not there are many real
points but here's another one that we
have to remember
is that um there were
multiple
very simple and direct things that could
have been done
just to
stop
this tragedy from happening
or at a minimum to uh to to mitigate the
harm
there are multiple simple direct things
i could have done
that could be done to save lives
potentially all of the lives
okay
like here's one thing
starting starting point lock the door to
the
school the guy's got a a rifle it's not
that's not gonna keep him out forever
it's gonna buy you some more time
lock all the doors
they didn't even do that
actually have armed security on the
premises
and someone who is willing to engage
and he was well trained another thing
that could have been done
okay many many things could have been
done police could have been the police
had 12 minutes to show up before the guy
even got into school
i'm just wondering what were all the
cops in the area doing that they they
couldn't get there within 12 minutes
like what's more important in that
moment in that small town than a maniac
walking around with a rifle
shooting
so there are lots of things that could
have been done
and we don't need to talk about
gun control gun regulations
that's got nothing to do with this
you know early on we were told by the
left that oh this was a failure see you
said you said that all you need is
security but there was security and it
didn't work no there wasn't apparently
there was no form of security in that
school so here's what every school in
america should have
every single school in america should
have multiple trained armed security
personnel on staff
and i and i keep emphasizing trained
like people that know what they're doing
and that are willing to do it when the
time comes
that last part well you can't really
know for sure until the time comes but
if they're well trained you look at
their background
i think you want to look especially into
into retired military ex-military people
have been in situations like this
who've been battle tested
get as many of those kinds of guys as
you possibly can um have them there
have one door in the school
that uh is the entrance of the school
and every other door is locked
and if there's an active shooter
situation you go into your lockdown
drill you actually do it you lock all
the doors
if all those things that happened this
tragedy would have been avoided
more than likely
yeah here we are talking about
things congress can do
what do you need congress to do lock the
freaking door
okay we don't need congress for that
all right moving to this
more cowardice this is a u.s secretary
of education miguel cardano he was in a
house education and labor committee
hearing yesterday and he was asked about
schools that
assist in the gender transition of
children
without uh parental consent how does he
feel about that as the secretary of
education and this is an official policy
in lots of these schools in fact an
official policy of the administration of
the administration itself how does he
feel about that what does he say about
it let's listen
do you believe that school districts
should keep a child's involvement and
gender transition a secret from their
parents
sir i
i would love to answer questions on the
budget which is why i'm here and i think
what what i'm saying secretary these are
policies that your administration stands
on you're asking me to fund your budget
and these are policies that you stand
for
it's completely relevant to why you're
here today it's a simple question and
answer the question do you think the
schools should keep it a secret from
their parents
if their children are involved in gender
transition parents listen parents and
schools must work together to support
students and i do strongly support and
if you look through the work that we've
uh supported and and our policies and
our practices we want parents should
schools ever keep that a secret from
parents
excuse me
should schools ever keep it a secret
from parents
if their children are involved
in gender transition school should only
be secret from parents
schools should be partnering with
parents in communication and there are
times where schools
are
working and supporting students on
issues that are very sensitive but i do
believe that parents should be connected
with schools and in many cases
working together is what's going to help
the student i have spoken to students
who've shared
whatever situation is at the home that
they felt safe at the school and we have
to be careful not to um
try to turn this into something that
it's not our schools are safe places for
our students and our teachers are often
the front liners when it comes to
supporting students uh when they have
issues uh in their lives that's a very
bizarre answer uh mr mr chairman i yield
back
so that's just a really roundabout way
uh with all of the with all the
bureaucrats speak a really roundabout
way of saying yeah i think that that uh
we should keep this from parents
yeah he finally gets around to it but
this is yet another example of
institutional cowardice now i don't know
a lot about miguel cardona uh maybe he
is himself an lgbt extremist
that wouldn't surprise me that by
administration is hiring a lot of those
types but that's not
that's not my
that's not the impression you
immediately get when you listen he he
comes off just like your standard
bureaucrat
who uh is not interested he's just there
because he's there and he's trying to
justify his job and he likes the power
and influence that he has in his
position that's the main thing that he's
worried about that's how he comes off
anyway
um
does he
actually think was that guy right there
that dude
does he does he really think that it's a
good idea that we should be
transitioning children is he
is he really into that does he actually
think that's good
it's joe biden i mean to the extent that
joe biden thinks anything does he think
that
well probably not
but it's actually worse it's worse than
being an extremist
if you're an extremist you're a true
believer
then at least when it comes down to it
you can claim at judgment day you can
claim that you were deluded and you had
you just didn't you didn't know you were
mistaken i don't think that excuse is
going to cut it but
you'll have that to go on you could try
that one out
but so many of the people who
have allowed and have facilitated these
situations in our schools
they really do know better i think
they're they're not really true
believers
but
they allow it to happen because they
don't really care they're actually kind
of indifferent to it but who cares if
kids are yeah this is crazy it's crazy
that we're doing this to kids
transitioning a child trying to turn a
boy into girls crazy but i don't care i
don't care about these kids like that's
their mentality it's indifference
and also cowardice they're not going to
stand up against it and but the main
thing they're worried about is their own
influence and power that's all they care
about
nothing in it for them to take a stand
against this so they don't
which i think is the is the worst
like that's that puts you at the lowest
level that makes you the the greatest
scumbag of all
um
kind of related to this so the backlash
against ricky gervais is continuing
uh because of the you know the one joke
routine he did about uh about
transgenderism and his netflix special
the website mary sue is a good
representative sample says last year
netflix faced intense controversy over
dave chappelle's comedy special the
closer which included a number of
transphobic jokes there was backlash
from audience walkouts among staff
condemnation even resignation now
netflix is proving that they learned
exactly nothing from that ordeal and the
platform has premiered another wildly
anti-trans comedy special this one from
ricky gervais
uh gervais is a special drop today and
immediately people were sharing just how
horrible it is but however awful you're
expecting it to be i don't think anyone
anything can prepare you for the level
of violent bigotry gervais put out
after just a few minutes he starts on a
tired about trans women in rape there's
a deep obsession with trans people's
genitals and he deliberately misgenders
his hypothetical trans villain
throughout so it goes on and on about
how it's violent and extreme and all
this kind of stuff now they're dubbing
the whole thing an anti-trans special
but
as far as i haven't watched the the
routine yet
but as far as i know that's the main the
main part there where he talks about it
that's not it's not that's not the
subject of the uh
of the entire special
but this is of course what the left
always does is that is that uh you know
if you mention this kind of thing at all
then you're obsessed with it meanwhile
it's like the only thing they talk about
this is the lgbt trans like the only
thing they talk about
but if you talk about it at all
to disagree with them then you're the
one who's obsessed with it
i thought uh andrew klavan made a
brilliant point about this
and something he tweeted he says here's
a question how come i find ricky
gervais's anti-god atheist jokes
hilarious but transgender people find
his anti-trans jokes offensive my theory
is that it's because i actually believe
in god
i think that's a that's a a very good
point i was thinking about this too
because i was watching there was another
clip from uh gervais's special that was
circulating and this is one i think it's
one from a netflix account like this is
the joke these are the jokes that
netflix actually wants these are the
clips they want to have out there where
gervais is doing his uh you know his
religion jokes because gervais is a
died in the wool
atheist
um
and he's a and so he's and he's still an
atheist that hasn't changed
right because it as it turns out it's
you don't need you don't need to be you
don't actually need to be religious
to believe that men are men and women
are women
um
and i i think what what clavin points
out is a good is a good point
that
there's this insecurity
um
among the gender ideologues in general
and this is why they this is why there's
this obsession with affirmation they
constantly need to be affirmed
they have this uh they have all you know
these words they have words that they
need you to say to them
even if they know you probably don't
even believe it they just need to hear
it out of your mouth
they constructed this web
for themselves and they need everyone
around them to constantly affirm them
because of their deep insecurity
and at some level just like i talked
about the bureaucrats
who go along with this
but don't really believe it
there's really a question that is to
what extent anyone really believes this
i mean that's i guess we can't really
know for sure because we can't see
inside anybody's mind does anyone really
believe
that
somebody
you know
a a person with a vagina who's carrying
a a a child in her womb it could be a
man does anyone actually believe that
um i think very few people do
but there's this insecurity that's why
it cannot it just it cannot withstand
any scrutiny and it certainly cannot be
you can't tell jokes about it
um now i will say that i often don't
find the god jokes funny that atheists
tell because i think often the jokes
aren't really trying to be funny
they're just kind of bitter and angry
and not very clever more of a more of a
speech than a joke
that's and that's most of
the anti-god atheist jokes that i've
heard from stand-up comedians you listen
to is like they're not even trying to
tell a joke here they're just mad and
this is a this is their own little
anti-god homily so i'm not laughing at
it because i'm not even supposed to it's
not even it's not even there's no
attempt here at wit or anything like
that
um but i can laugh at i can laugh at any
joke if it's a good joke
not so with the gender ideologues though
yeah before we get to the comments um
you know we have my what i've uh
so i sort of regret dubbing my swag
shack but that's what we decided to go
with over the daily wire that's my merch
store dailywire.com
and uh we have i mean look i'm biased
it's not a competition but i do think
we have hands down the best merchandise
at the daily wire i just do i think i
think our merchandise is great because
it's all very it's all like memes and
just inside jokes as all the merchandise
is and i want to tell you about our
latest thing this is just in time for
memorial day which uh and you will see
me you will actually see this this
product debuted on a video that we're
gonna be coming out on memorial day i'll
be wearing this because i'm gonna be
doing a little bit of grilling and if
you're doing some grilling and you're a
dad that means that you need an apron
with a little
snappy
saying on it everybody knows that and so
we have this i want to show you this
this is you need this for memorial day
or anytime you're cooking so you've got
your apron and uh and you need to make
sure everybody knows what your pronouns
are and it's the apron that says my
pronouns are chef and chef self so this
is just good it's like when you're in
the kitchen or you're out on the at the
grill
and you're cooking that means in that
moment right that's how you identify it
doesn't mean you identify as that all
the time but you want to make sure
people know that and they will respect
your pronouns as chef and chef self so
go to the
dailywire.com go to the store right now
and go to my store and buy your apron
right now let's get to the comments
[Music]
uh logan says
hilarious to hear matt talking like he's
some kind of badass would you just go
charging into gunfire in that situation
easy to monday morning quarterback the
police from where you're sitting
yeah i already i think i covered this
yesterday it is it's easy for me to say
that's true
um that's there's a lot of things that
are easy for me to say doesn't mean it's
wrong
you know
uh like it's it's
if somebody commits uh
medical malpractice while performing
brain surgery
because they're being negligent
it's it's easy for me because i'm not
it's like brain surgery is difficult and
i've i don't know how to do it so it's
easy for me to sit here and say that's
bad you should not have done that you
were supposed to fix this person's brain
and said you caused even worse brain
damage that's a that's a bad thing
you're being irresponsible it is very
easy for me to say that it's also true
and the other thing is that i have not
signed up to be a brain surgeon
and so
the fact that i can't perform brain
surgery and that i'd be very bad at
performing brain surgery that's not a
failure on my part i never i never
agreed to do it
i never said to society hey you should
come to me for this i'm the guy i'm your
guy
so
not an issue
okay and it's the same thing if you're a
police officer i mean
uh if you if you're signing up to be in
these kinds of situations
then that's the job you sign up for if
you don't want to do it then go get
another job i think that's very
reasonable isn't it
is that an unreasonable point of view
if there's a certain job that you don't
want to do
don't sign up for the job
what exactly is your is your issue with
that
not i'm not sure i understand
and i also understand that uh that
police officers want to go home to their
families and want to preserve their own
lives
but
preserving your own life as a police
officer that can't be
your number one priority all the time
given the job you signed up for
if you're never willing to put someone
else's life ahead of your own even the
life of a young child
then you're in the wrong line of work
um so that's just lazy i mean as much as
you say it's it's easy and lazy for me i
think this this criticism from you is a
lazy one
monday morning quarterback i don't know
monday morning this isn't a football
game you idiot
it's not monday morning quarterback i
think they were standing outside where
kids were getting slaughtered
that's a bad thing
um
all right but thanks for listening his
dudeness says not to be a conspiracy guy
in the room but how does a kid that
lives with his grandmother on his 18th
birthday have enough money to buy two
brand new daniel defense ars worth
almost five thousand dollars ammo plus
optics and body armor
and a seventy thousand dollar uh
pickup and an unlocked back door i
really think those are legit questions
uh they all are all completely
legitimate questions you say this is
because there's nothing conspiratorial
about these questions these are all good
questions and i have the same ones
um i don't
i i'm not sure what conspiracy they
would even point to so i'm not sure
exactly what you have in mind
but i have the same questions there's
nothing wrong with asking it and and
here's the thing the the more
that they are vague about this and
they're not up front the more you're
going to get actual conspiracy theories
okay and you're already starting to see
that i mean i i i'm sure if i looked
you know
on the internet and i when i went
searching for it you could find that
there are already people
who are you know doing the sandy hook
thing with this like they claim with
sandy hook that was all big hoax and
these were crisis actors um which of
course was completely absurd
and i don't know if that conspiracy has
started with this one but you're going
to start getting stuff like that
more of it the more vague you are
because when you don't give people
information they start filling in the
blanks themselves
yet another reason to be up front
uh rku says there are deadbeat dads for
sure but we add society needs to discuss
how many fathers are kicked out of the
home by the mother because it's
extremely common and we pay zero
attention to it
totally agree that's why i said
yesterday the problem of fatherless
homes and you know uh single mothers and
everything
you know being a single mother is not
the ideal
and we should be able to say that
but i did say
you know just because single month
doesn't mean it's not necessarily your
fault but it could be
i mean there are plenty of single
mothers out there who it's it's their
fault that there's basically what they
chose because they kicked their husband
out for no good reason
and that that happens
so i think i think both
no matter who's at fault for it and very
often both parties are somewhat at fault
the fact is that fatherless homes is a
problem so
um
joseph says i'm actually highly curious
about statistics regarding children from
motherless homes that would be
interesting it's a very small sample
size the fact is this is very very rare
it's not it's not unheard of but it's
very rare it's probably why there aren't
very many statistics for it
um gary says there's a fair bit of
smugness about matt's uh evocation of
his family life
perfect wife kids and home life and the
implication that much of it is because
of his wisdom and good life choices
i like him a lot but you can be a as
good a husband and father as you want
doesn't mean your kids are going to
listen to you or not go off the rails or
your what seemed perfect wife won't fall
out of love with you and want you gone
i'm not sure when i ever said any of
that
i have a perfect family it's because
what have i have i ever said that but i
have a perfect family because of my
great wisdom and my great life choices
most of the family stories that i tell
like oftentimes it involves me you know
i'm the punch line in a lot of those
stories so i'm not exactly sure where
you're getting that and but it i don't
disagree with you that you could do
everything right
as a parent and your child still goes
off the rails as you say
that's one of the
existential fears that you have as a
parent it's like the dread that kind of
undergirds everything all the time one
of them you know there's a lot of dread
and fear and anxiety that comes up being
a parent just part of the territory
um and one of it is just this like sort
of increasing realization especially as
kids get older that they are their own
person they have their own mind and
you can influence them but you can't
actually
directly control them that's why people
say they see kids that are freaking out
or whatever and they say oh that kid's
out of control you need to control your
kid well
uh what you really mean is that that kid
is not being you need to have more
influence over that kid
because you really can't the kid's not a
puppet he's not a robot you can program
you can't directly now the only when a
kid's young the way that you can
physically control them is you can pick
them up and take them out of a situation
which you should do and oftentimes
parents are reluctant even to do that so
there's that kind of control but outside
of that
um
no what you really have is influence
you're trying to influence your child
and but as that
as they grow older that only goes so far
all that being said
um
you know there's kids going off the
rails that's true but then there's your
kid becoming a mass
shooter
and um i think certainly if you're doing
if you
being a loving and attentive parent and
trying to do your best because no one's
gonna be perfect but you're trying to do
your best and you're there for your kid
it is just very very very astronomically
unlikely
that they quote go off the rails to that
extent
which is why we can assume when you see
uh people that are doi behaving in that
way that you can just assume ahead of
time and you'll almost always be right
that they had a horrible home life and
really bad parents may not be right 100
percent of time but most of the time you
will be
um
jay stoss says matt was spot on when he
said that people turn to the internet
for companionship because they've given
up on life having relationships with
other people etc it's basically why i do
it but the thing is if i hadn't turned
to the internet i would have never known
about matt walsh and the sweet baby gang
there's a silver lining in everything i
guess well i'm glad you found some
sense of belonging in the show in the
sweet baby gang and i appreciate that
but also don't give up on life and human
relationships man don't do that i mean
there's a whole world out there there's
an entire life to be lived
i don't know how old you are but i know
that you've only encountered a small
sliver of the world and of the people in
it to this point in your life no matter
how old you are it's like the tiniest
little portion you've experienced so you
can't give up on something when you've
seen and experienced so little of it
is my point you got to get out there i
mean still watch this show but like get
out there and experience life okay
there's there's a lot about life that's
that's dismal but
also quite a lot of beauty and joy and
adventure and so on
uh that was my inspirational message of
the year probably and i'll get back to
being a cynical bastard
you know films these days are mostly
garbage the only exception i can think
of right now is the documentary what is
a woman which uh if i'm not mistaken
premieres june 1st i think yes that's
what we're talking about what is
woman.com go there become a member so
you can watch on june 1st aside from
that pretty slim pickings what happened
no that's easy hollywood gave up on
itself morally bankrupt and
ideologically shackled its most high
profile production these days consists
of cancelling actors and comedians for
even the faintest whisper of counter
leftist sentiment gina carano for
example an actress on disney's the
mandalorian she got expelled from the
magic kingdom for tweeting unthinkable
ideas like neighbors should be nice to
each other an election should be fair
who would have thought
and uh disney didn't like it but we
loved it that's why we're making good in
our promise to uncancel gina by starring
her in our summer blockbuster movie
terror on the prayer which premieres
exclusively on the datawire on june 14th
set on the plains of montana this gritty
thriller follows a family of pioneers as
they defend themselves from a vicious
gang of outlaws hell-bent on revenge
we're giving you a sneak peek next week
when the trailer drops on june 1st and
to top it all off the official terran
the prairie movie poster is in our shop
right now you can buy it at
dailywire.com
shop from special guests on our podcast
to unflinching films and documentaries
that aren't afraid to confront the truth
everything we do with the daily wire is
fearless and this is our invitation for
you to come and be fearless with us
become a member at dailywire.com
gina
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
now at first blush this may seem to be
another example of stupid pc word
policing but as you'll see that's not
exactly correct it is actually an
example of extremely maniacally stupid
pc word pleasing um stupid on multiple
levels and from every conceivable angle
the san francisco chronicle reports the
word chief will no longer be used in
reference to job titles in the san
francisco unified school district in an
effort school officials said to avoid
the words connotation with native
americans
in a statement to the newspaper a
spokeswoman for the district further
explained
while there are many opinions on the
matter our leadership team agreed that
given that native american members of
our community have expressed concern
over the use of the title we are no
longer going to use it
they still haven't come up with a
replacement term yet which is why if you
go to the district's website you will
still find this hideous slur being used
in fact there's a whole section list
listing the division chiefs
and there are currently 13 chiefs
leading 13 tribes such as chief
technology officer melissa dodd chief
general counsel danielle houck
and chief of staff jill hugandik
what will we call these women now if
she's not chief jill huggin dick what is
she and what word is safe leader head
captain master commander overlord these
words are all problematic too they're
either too militant too patriarchal or
they recall the troubling legacy of
slavery
maybe there should be no titles at all
maybe jill hogan dick is just jill
hugandik but then you've effectively
demoted all of these women
and they are almost all women by the way
12 of the 13 people leading the district
are women and what's the point of virtue
signaling with a leadership team
comprised of women
if you can't give them titles that
denote their leadership
this would also uh probably be a good
time to mention the minor detail that
chief
is not a native american word chief is
an english word which comes from french
which comes from latin
the french word is chef meaning head or
ruler or somebody in authority i'm not
sure how we got from there to chef as in
the guy with a funny hat in the kitchen
my etymological knowledge in this area
has already been exhausted but what i
can say for absolute certain is that
chief has been in usage since the 1300s
and wasn't applied to native americans
until sometime in the 1700s
english settlers had good reason to use
english words to describe native
americans namely the reason is that they
they spoke english and people generally
use words in the language they speak as
opposed to languages they don't speak
so the premise here is false and that's
enough to explain why this whole thing
is very stupid but as i said this is not
just stupid it's extremely maniacally
stupid and understand why i consider
that consider what they're actually
trying to do
if chief was a native american word
which it isn't but if it was then they
would be erasing native american
influence on the english language
they aren't doing that in this case
because the premise is false but they're
trying to
ostensibly for the sake of native
americans and supposedly at the best of
native americans they are they think
erasing native american representation
in the english language
they believe this is an example of
native american language being adopted
by english-speaking people and their
goal is to
undo that influence
see the left always complains about
minorities being allegedly erased and
marginalized and yet that's exactly what
they're trying to do here again
when it comes to native americans
specifically the left has adopted sort
of this addition by subtraction strategy
while claiming that they want native
americans to be represented all they
have ever done for years is just erase
every mention or depiction or reference
or supposed reference to native
americans that they can find all of the
indian mascots and team names are being
changed every nod to indian culture is
being rooted out and cancelled most
recently a school in indiana came under
intense scrutiny for a half-time
ceremony involving students dressed in
traditional indian attire the school
been doing that for many years it was
supposed to be an homage to indian
culture and history
but it was deemed racist somehow for
reasons that are never made clear
all of these sorts of things have been
as the left says problematized
they've even snuffed out native american
depictions that were made by native
americans the lando lakes butter girl
famously canceled a couple of years ago
was partially the work of a native
american artist
and they got rid of that too
indeed in a culture obsessed with
representation
there's no question that native
americans are represented far less than
they used to be
i mean you used to find references to
them everywhere in many areas of life
even in children's games back in the
dark ages of the 90s as recently as then
kids would would play you know cowboys
and indians they were part of your games
they were just part of the culture they
were part of the language it was just
like there was there was a certain
presence there
and all of that is gone now
the representation bean counters have
seen to it that indian culture and
people are represented far less than
they used to be
and the thing is to me this is quite sad
because i actually find native american
history to be remarkable
and important one of my favorite books
of all time is empire of the summer moon
about the comanches whenever i'm
traveling with my family if there's a
native american museum nearby we always
visit it we go to native american
festivals and art exhibits my kids
currently have a teepee set up in their
in my garage
my son likes to run around the yard with
a spear that he made out of a stick and
a sharp rock now this all would be
considered cultural appropriation these
days i suppose you can call it that if
you want to i don't really care but the
history is fascinating
and um it's even more fascinating that i
as i'm told a racist right-wing white
supremacist ethnocentric bigot have more
interest in and respect for that history
than the culturally sensitive leftists
do
and but it's actually not that
surprising when you think about it of
course they want to erase native
american history they want to erase all
history
there's a reason they haven't replaced
most of the monuments and statues
they've torn down and when they do
replace them they're likely to put it to
put in its place a monument to some
unremarkable person who died a few years
ago like george floyd
they are not principally interested in
rewriting history or giving their own
version of it they do have their own
version that's the 16 19 project
but really history itself
is an inconvenient reality to a leftist
they would rather erase the whole thing
there's too much in history especially
native american history but really all
history the whole history of the human
race
that's troublesome to the left and inco
incongruent with their claims and their
narratives
so they just don't want to talk about it
at all
their priority is to sever all people
from their history from history itself
and have us all live as though the world
itself came into being at the turn of
this current millennium
they don't want any of us to be rooted
too deeply or too connected with our
ancestors or too in touch with our past
because what they want
are blank slates
non-descript automatons that they can
mold and shape
as they see fit
that's what this is all about
and it's why bringing us back to the
beginning
the san francisco unified school
district is cancelled
i will leave it there for today and the
week have a great weekend talk to you on
tuesday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin